the first stage of the Christian
philosophy debates I mark as beginning
in 1931 with the socio t française de
philosophie session devoted to the
problem of Christian philosophy and I
think that it ends sometime in 1932
before the publication of several
important books 18 jul sones spirit of
medieval philosophy this is the
translation of it those were his Gifford
lectures that he delivered in 1931 in
1932 Maurice blown dells the problem
native philosophy catholique also
published in 1932 and a book that I
don't have here shocked more attends
essay on Christian philosophy which is
published a little bit later he gave a
presentation which is a bridge point
between his his presentation during the
associate a process to philosophy
session and the book that would later
become his essay on Christian philosophy
in which he targeted blown down by the
way lonedell targeting Jill stone in
this book and more attend Jill so
targeting blown del in this book among
other people the debate was already well
going by that time a lot of controversy
a lot of lines being drawn so in my book
the translations that I have have some
of the documents from this early part of
the debate the 1931 to say mid nineteen
thirty-two I don't have all of it in
part because you can only include so
much and also because the societal on
says do philosophy would not actually
give permission to have the entirety of
the session translated only Jill Souls
portion that session like I said a
portion of which remains untranslated at
this time but which I do have
translations of that I can supply people
with unofficially if they would like
that session really marks the beginning
of the debates
and the reason I choose that is because
you have to have some way of marking
when something begins as a historian
granted there's a whole prehistory of
the debates there's a lot of things
going into it some of the the major
lines had already been drawn before that
but that's a good point of demarcation
so what took place well in in early
nineteen thirty-one there were already
some things being published about
Christian philosophy and the societal
française de philosophie had arranged to
have a meeting a debate and this is what
they did year after year after year they
would bring together some of the great
French philosophers on a given topic
sometimes they would actually bring in
some other people and they would set out
the different sides they would make
presentations and then they would argue
with each other and that's what took
place here so Jill so 80 Angeles ohm and
Leo brunschwig had already clashed about
the nature of tow mystic philosophy was
it really philosophy this is a great
debate that was going on Jill soul was
on one side and Jacques more attend with
his ally on that side saying yes
definitely it is philosophy it's a
robust philosophy it is indebted to
Christianity but it is still
philosophical on the other side of the
imran shaikh also Emile Grenier who had
recently staked out a position saying
there is no such thing as Christian
philosophy tome ISM augustinian ism a
galleon ism all these attempts to have a
Christian philosophy at all been
colossal failures and the lines were
drawn so it would be Jill so on one side
and the young gray here on the other
side meanwhile sort of in their corners
would be Jacques motor town
Jill so and Jill sones old teacher also
blown Dells old teacher Leon brunschwig
those were the rationalist versus the
the what you could call existential
Thomas now another group wasn't in the
debate at that time but they were
actually opposed to Christian philosophy
that was the neo scholastic Thomas who
had said that no tome ism in so far it
is philosophy it's purely philosophical
and as soon as God starts coming in the
picture or anything like that it becomes
theology and they were sort of
capitulating to the rationalist but
there were some other positions
represented as well that didn't make it
into the debates blondell was not able
to attend the sessions lonedell it had
some severe health problems that had
begun in the late 1920s that actually
necessitated him stepping down as a
professor of philosophy and he had
become progressively more and more blind
he really could not see much at all he
had to work through having a secretary
read things to him and then the
secretary would take dictation it's
remarkable how much he actually got done
well now had a different position than
the thomaston and actually blown dells
position on to him ism was changing at
this time lonedell was a completely
original thinker who was revitalized in
Christian philosophy from the ground up
and like a lot of original thinkers he
was he was misunderstood by his own
allies as a matter of fact there's
really if you look at it closely there's
no good reason why he and gel song
should have been at odds like they were
but they were so let me lay out the the
sides you have the you Thomas over here
proponents of Christian philosophy you
have the rationalist over here opponents
of Christian philosophy you have blown
del staking at his own position for
Christian philosophy but in a different
understanding of it than Jill cell and
more
also very critical Jill so Moret ants
position Jill saw more attend return the
favor by criticizing blown Dells
position my contention is they actually
misunderstood each other quite a bit and
some of that may have been due to pass
history that I'll talk about in another
video some of it may have just been an
uncharacteristic lack of Christian
charity on the part of those those
participants towards each other so the
battle lines get drawn how are they
drawn they come together gelsin gives
his presentation and he and Brekke a
start going back and forth and it is a
complete round she also snakes out of
position that argues that there is a
Christian philosophy he has some very
beautiful passages about that I'm not
going to give you those here because I'm
reading those into podcasts Bray here
gives this presentation Jill sombrero
you go back and forth then Jacques more
attend gives his position and this is
the first place where more attend stakes
out a position that hill later revised
and then revised again and revised again
and continue revising through several
different steps adding more and more
each each point making it more and more
precise more attend comes up with the
notion of Christian philosophy as
philosophy in a Christian state as
opposed to philosophies essence which is
a historical not tied any particular
system or culture philosophy within a
Christian culture develops as Christian
philosophy or is more attendance and a
Christian regime then brunch fig says
his peace and brunch thing says some
startling things he says I would not
recognize myself as a philosopher if
Christianity had not existed he even
admits that there could be some figures
that would embody Christian philosophy
mob rush he thinks Nicholas mob rauch is
one of them and Pascal is actually
them and he says Pascal has a way of
philosophizing that is not that of the
Philosopher's but really what he thinks
is that Christianity is something that's
going to be left behind as mankind
becomes brighter and brighter to take
out you know one of the memes or catch
phrases that the rights like to use they
would gradually Slough it off he and
Jill soul get into a back-and-forth
conversation and it's very different
than the one with Brea there's no
definite winner there is no definite
conclusion and you can see the two sides
working themselves out in the process so
how does it come about that Maurice
blown down blind nearly blind rather
living apart from Paris outside of the
occurrence of intellectual events comes
into this Christian philosophy well at
least with the associated francaise
difference of feet session it happens
because he is invited to participate via
correspondence and this is how he
actually did it through some other
sessions as well the socio TT tude
philosophique for example he is invited
to contribute because he's a major
philosopher he's considered a brilliant
mind and he has a lot to say about
Christian philosophy although actually
his preferred term is not Christian
philosophy but as you see here
philosophy catholique Catholic
philosophy and we can talk about reasons
why that is in another video so what
takes place involves a little bit of
fast dealings on blown dolls part kind
of uncharacteristic because he was a guy
who was scrupulously honest and he was
always very charitable to his opponents
somehow that went out the window with
respect to do so hillsong was another
guy like that who took offense at what
blown del did when he didn't happen and
it could be because their positions were
actually so
close and and in some ways required each
other in order to work that may be there
it's something like the fight between
brothers I don't know I'd have to think
about that in any case here's what
happened Jill song gives blown down a
copy of the outline to his presentation
blown dell has that read to him and
writes a response to it or rather
dictates a response to that goes to Jill
sol-gel soul thinks that that's what
he's going to hear read at the session
she also writes the rest of his
presentation takes into account blown
Dells original criticisms which are not
quite as trenchant as the later ones and
lonedell is not actually supposed to
have a copy of that blown doubt gets a
copy of that through some behind the
scenes pulling strings and he rewrites
his response his letter that he's going
to use and he's very critical of Jill so
and he's it's not just that he's
critical it's that he's deeply great he
is targeting Jill song and some of the
weaker points of the Joe Saul Jacques
Moret an existential Thomas position
he's hitting him and sometimes you might
say where it counts not death blows
because blown Dells philosophy will fill
in the gaps of Jill souls just like Jill
Soames and more attends will fill in the
gaps in in bloom Dells but enough to to
sort of sever the connection between
those and those sides then split apart
at the same time the the people who have
already gotten involved that have staked
out a claim you might say briea lonedell
brunschwig more attempt they start
publishing their own pieces and they are
further developing their claims they're
responding to each other blondell was
was actually targeting Jill soul
specifically in his piece
attached to the associative process to
the philosophy session which is
translated in here but he also responds
to Bray EA directly in another piece
that's also translated brunch eggs did a
false the value that falls from
comparacion comes out that ties in with
it as well that that's sort of the the
ending point of brunschwig contribution
one other thing that's taking place in
this period which makes it in some ways
kind of a fallow period there the the
very important participants blown del
morte an Jill song to a lesser extent
Sarah Tiana and people like bunch Dan
Berrigan they are gearing up there
thinking they are working out their
thoughts and more detail Jill song is
going to England and giving the Gifford
lectures and here he's working out is it
his understanding of Christian
philosophy further this is an advanced
beyond his presentation at the
associated Francis de philosophie he'll
actually reverse some of his stances on
things like the nature of augustinian
philosophy as philosophy and that those
sort of shifts are starting to take
place here as a matter of fact he
changes his position on Saint handsome
not in this book but by 1933 1934 before
he'd actually said Anselm's feed n
squadrons intellect 'um is one of the
definitions of Christians lawsuit later
he'll reverses position blown Dell is
getting ready to publish the problem to
the philosophy catholique more attend in
his philosophy is going through several
transformations that will ultimately
culminate in the essay on Christian
philosophy which will get reworked later
on in his later 1930s works like science
and wisdom and
the degrees of knowledge those sorts of
sorts of texts where he'll talk a little
bit more about Christian philosophy
that's what's going on in this